[Applause]
today the members of the G7 are
launching The Joint declaration support
for Ukraine to make it clear that our
support will last long into the future
this starts a process by which each of
our Nations and any other Nation who
wishes to participate will negotiate
long-term bilateral security commitments
with and to Ukraine we're going to help
Ukraine build a strong capable defense
across land air and sea and from which
we'll Force the whether to be a force of
stability in the region and deter
against any and all threats I think it's
a powerful statement a powerful
statement of our commitment to Ukraine
as it defends its freedom today and as
it rebuilds the future for and as we're
going to be there as long as that takes
the outcome of the NATO Summit and
villainous is very much needed and
meaningful successful Ukraine and I'm
grateful to all leaders in NATO
countries for very practical and I'm
presenting its support considering the
case of our relation support for Ukraine
today there are security guarantees
for Ukraine on the way to Nato an
important package of security guarantees
Ukrainian delegation is bringing home
significant security victory for the
Ukraine for our country for our people
for our children it opens for us
absolutely new security opportunities
and I thank everyone who made it
possible thank you dear colleagues
thanks you thanks Lithuanian and Ian
stautamer thank you very much
this concludes the speaking program
please remain seated for the family
photo